so where i left off in the last video my
buddies and i we had a business plan we
had a great idea to sell socks online we
went to an angel investor he had
originally given us five million dollars
he he valued what we already had at five
million dollars so since he was giving
us five million and we had five million
he got 50 of the company and we have the
other 50 we have 2 million total shares
and we took four of that million let's
say six months have passed we hired 50
people and we finally built a working
version of our website but we now are
about to run out of cash we still
haven't started selling things and we'll
actually have to start selling a lot of
things before we have enough money to
support ourselves so we need to go start
raising money again and we also want to
spend money marketing and all the rest
so we go to some professional investors
we'll go to seed venture capitalists and
we're going to do our series a round of
funding which just means our first kind
of professional venture capital round of
funding
we finally some guys find a team that
they like us
and
we start getting to the negotiation they
say you know what you guys say you need
10 million dollars we believe you we
know that that's what it takes and we
think you have a good business so let's
see let me say that we need to raise 10
million dollars so that i make that
clear
and we need it for you know ongoing
ongoing expenses
and of course we'll have a big business
plan and everything that further fleshes
this out and we also had need um you
know we're going to do some marketing
marketing
etc etc so they said you know we have 10
million dollars and we think this is a
hot space because we know those other
vcs across the street also invested in
an online undergarment play and we know
that that's the hot thing right now so
we are also going to do it
so
the question now is what do they get for
their 10 million dollars so once again
we get into this what is the company
worth right now so once again they're
going to do a pre-money valuation whoops
pre-money valuation so what is this
whole thing worth right now
so that they'll say you know the idea is
good you know yeah you know they won't
like break down they'll they won't say
oh the idea is worth five million and
the you know but but the general idea is
hopefully what from that stage where the
post money valuation was 10 million
dollars right
back here is 10 million then we did a
bunch of work we used some of this 5
million dollars we did a bunch of work
hopefully we added value if you know if
we added value our our
our value of this stuff now this you
know we turn this cash into other types
of assets like a website and and other
things and and knowledge in our firm and
expertise and all that stuff hopefully
now what we have here is worth more than
10 million dollars right otherwise we
kind of destroyed wealth we were kind of
we were
we were and all of this is very you know
it's kind of
it's it's very intangible it's very hard
for someone to really place a value on
things at this point a lot of vcs they
kind of swing for the fences they're
like you know what
these guys have a 10 chance of being
worth a billion dollars and a 90 chance
of being worth zero if i make 10 of
these bets at least one of them is going
to pay off and make my whole fund and so
that's how they kind of think so at this
level you know they'll do some hard
negotiating but it oftentimes is going
to not at this level this is where we
are right now it's kind of what other
people got for this stage of a company
they say oh you know you have a pretty
good built out website those other guys
who had a pretty good built out website
at this point you know those are that
those guys across the street they had to
pay they have to give a 20 million pre
pre money valuation
but you know you guys are are a little
bit you know your market isn't quite as
big as the broader undergarments market
you're just socks so you know the
opportunity isn't as big so we'll give
you
we'll give you a
a 15 million dollar pre-money valuation
15 million so what they they're saying
that what we have right now is worth 15
million dollars
and that's pretty good that's i mean if
you if if that were reality if that
really is worth 15 million dollars then
what are our shares worth right now
notice they haven't given us any money
this is the pre-money valuation so 15
million dollars divided by 2 million
shares right that's how many we have
right now so what is the value per share
15 million divided by 2
is
what 7
seven fifty
per share that's pretty good because
back here remember this this is kind of
a scenario that didn't happen that was
kind of a negative scenario but back
here when we the pre-money was five
million dollars for a million shares it
was five dollars per share and then it
became ten million dollars for two
million shares still five dollars per
share but before and after this round
that angel said oh you know your shares
are worth about five dollars per share
now this vc who's a professional
investor and has teams of mbas making
spreadsheets for them says that actually
what we have right here is worth 750 a
share so just over that six those six
months we actually got a 50 return on
our shares if you believe that and you
know the angel investor is happy he he
feels good about it he he got this was
vindication for his his bet on us so we
feel good we feel like we've given him
at least in the short term of return
so anyway we get a 15 million dollar
pre-money valuation
and i'll let you think about this one
what's the post money valuation what
happens when you layer on
the 10 million dollars from this venture
firm
the 10 million actually just to make it
simple to make the math simple
let's say that
we're raising seven and a half million
let's say that we wanted 10 million but
we were we we were hoping for 20 million
pre-money valuation because that's what
the other guys got and since they're
only giving us a 15 million pre-money we
just don't want to take as many shares
from them because we don't want to give
as much of the company away so we're
just going to take seven and a half
million because we think that's just
enough that we need to keep going
so we do that we take seven and a half
million dollars from
this
seed venture capitalist
we take seven and a half million dollars
and he essentially valued our old shares
at
at 750 per share
so for seven and a half million dollars
750 per share he should get another
million shares
so what we're going to do this angel
investor is probably sitting on our
board now because he owns so many of the
shares the board of directors of a firm
is essentially elected by the
shareholders so if you have 50 percent
of the shares you can put yourself on
the board and you could probably put
some other people on the board of
directors as well
so this is so here so we had 2 million
these guys got a million how many shares
do we have now we now will have 3
million shares so we have to issue
another million shares and what is our
post money valuation pre-money was 15
we have seven and a half million dollars
now our post money valuation is 22
and a half million
dollars and now what is how much what
percentage do each of us own so the
angel investor owns one million not out
of two million shares like he used to he
now owns one million out of three
million shares so now he owns 30 percent
he owns 30 percent
the
seed
vc he has a million out of
out of three million so he owns well
this is 33 in a third percent
the seed vc owns 33 and a third
percent
and then me and my buddies we
collectively own 33 and a third percent
and i have a fifth of that so i have a
little over five percent
so the founders that's us
we still have about a third of the
company and now we have the seven and a
half million we just raised plus we have
the million dollars of cash that we had
before we have eight and a half million
dollars to to keep on going with our
with our business fair enough so let me
draw so let's say another six months go
by
so our old balance sheet so let me draw
all of the shares
i want to do a couple of more rounds of
financing before i take the company
public
let's say so that's you know this is my
slice down here 200 000.
this is the angel investor
this is the seed
vc
and then of course let's say after i
don't know another six months we've
burned through the cash we have you know
we that we've marketed the website we
have only a million dollars left
and that's usually our trigger point for
when we want to raise more money in fact
we probably would have to do it at 2
million because we've raised more
employees and we're burning more cash
your cash burn is essentially how much
cash is going out of the door every
month because your business still isn't
making money and of course you have all
of the assets of the firm which
essentially you know it's a website and
offices and the knowledge some of it
intangible so you know you know website
and everything that comes in with it
your brand now you probably have because
you've marketed so people recognize
socksonline.com
i don't want to get you know i don't
know if that already exists so you know
forgive me if if i'm actually somehow um
insulting a real business out there uh
but you know you have a brand now
and so
you're almost ready you're actually
generating revenue but you're still kind
of cash flow negative you're generating
you're burning less money because people
are actually going to your site they're
buying stuff but you just need a little
bit more money you think to get
profitable right that's you know once
you get this amount of money you're
ready to go so you go to another vc once
again a lot of them turn your way but
one guy finally says okay i'll give you
some money and you say you know i need
five million dollars
he says fair enough i'm going to value
your your business at and let's say you
know we'll we're we're in an optimistic
world so we're doing up rounds up rounds
are when
your pre-money valuation of this round
is more than the post-money valuation of
the last round right so the value is
going up you're creating value it would
be a down round
like here they valued us at 15 million
dollars
right
while the post money of our last round
was 10 million so that was an up round
if these guys said no way think the
world has changed we're only going to
value all of this stuff at 8 million
then that would be a down round and no
one's happy about that we'll talk about
the repercussions of that in the future
why down rounds aren't good so
oftentimes you actually don't want to
get too good of a valuation because if
you get too good of a valuation in the
next round it might be hard to give get
people who can give you another a better
valuation so you might be forced to to
take a down round which which has
negative aspects but just quick and
dirty you need your prominent brand now
it's a little easier for you to raise
money
you go to some vc who specializes in
kind of helping people get to that
profitability stage
and what you do is you raise your series
b
and just put it simply it's an up round
your post money from your last round was
22 and a half million right 22.5 million
you've generated some value so now they
say you know what your business is worth
30 million
and you know you need another 10 million
to really pump up the marketing
so you need another 10 million
10 million
10 million to pump up the marketing how
many shares do they get well the
pre-money was 30 million
we had 3 million shares
so they're assigning us a value of
essentially dollars a share which is
great remember the first round the angel
gave us five dollars per share second
round we got seven fifty per share and
now we're getting ten dollars per share
so if we're selling him shares at ten
dollars per share we just have to issue
another million shares to get ten
million dollars
so another million shares and this goes
to vc2 the second vc and that's our
series b we raised 10 million dollars
fair enough so we've done one round of
angel investing and then we've gotten
our series a that gave us the seven and
a half million dollars and we did our
series b that gave us 10 million and we
could keep doing the series c series d
and so on and so forth and i'll continue
this in the next video